[Music]
in evening the odds news submitted by
Kimberly in parentheses mother love you
guys
a young man applied to a woman's college
to improve his chances of finding a
girlfriend Wow thirsty you'll accept
males are women college how's that work
they don't right so what is he doing
I didn't they do what if he identifies
as a woman there you go
no he says he's trying to get a woman
there you go
but he might identify as a woman trying
to get a woman there he goes even though
he has a penis there he goes I go but
there I guess and you know such college
does exist because when I was in college
I heard about this school called Mount
st. Mary's it's a nursing school and I
heard those 90 percent women and I was
like maybe I should go there damn you're
hella weak with your game I know or the
smarter the less conspicuous thing to do
is research where your school is and if
it's buying all women's school so that's
smart I'm saying the wings right now I
know so
so you're nearby you could you know you
could scout it out you're not so like
obvious you slowly invade so you're
right the word invading seems a bit
aggressive but maybe just a base what
would you and then just walk over maybe
like hey you invade he just party you
master laugh the car but you do scouting
up
but you do scout it out loudly now he's
not trying to admit a good word that's a
good word
my college son yeah our college son yeah
what the school together different time
in the same school what do the same what
did you go to ELAC to yeah he would do
the same junior college and actual
universities we went to a commuter
University so it's like literally people
that have like a full-time job and then
go to school full-time so they go in do
their [ __ ] leave so there's like no
school spirit like no one wants to stay
there it's like barren there's no school
life on campus things yeah I didn't have
my hot water rather went there then go
to ASU as a ethnic guy Arizona State
yeah come on what was bad about that Ben
ain't good for anything I think that
it's like how so maybe cuz Asians are in
yeah they were but back then it was like
what was going on you're getting jealous
no somos like mostly good looking like
it's good-looking white people that's it
yeah but you're exactly too exotic there
you were wrong good looking why people
fall it wasn't cool to be the the kind
of like this kid the ethnic guy that
with the skateboard it's cuz you didn't
own it yeah you would oniy
you wouldn't be mean by that let me
explain so the way you already pretty
you but the way you already set it up
was like it's not cool to be you know
the ethnic guy with the skateboard you
could have ruled it exactly you should
oh okay poor dog you should have been
like I'm one of a kind
with the skateboard invading you see the
word invading your guys's sports your
guys's culture like I'm [ __ ] cool
they're women it was my my mind was in
the right it wasn't in the right I was
weak minded about it good now though you
should go back if I oh that's what I
always fantasized if I could go back in
a time machine you look the same
you literally look this bad
go back in a time machine I would do it
dip go back thought I'd be so different
about we went to ASU and 94 yeah there's
old man here you got an old man in here
Intermediate School nobody yeah I'm old
but if I we're gonna time machine yeah I
would definitely I would not uh yeah I
do do things differently
Oh join a lot of the stuff I do get
involved that's what I say too I [ __ ]
up I fall I [ __ ] up the college
experience like in what ways I know what
I did wrong but what did he do wrong
please tell me I got in later cuz I was
rushing to just sign up because I didn't
prepare for it I didn't know that you
have to sign up and fall for the next
year's fall but I had good [ __ ]
grades man I could have got into any
like and I didn't challenge myself to
see where I stood in the realm of what
colleges I could get into and I think if
I challenge myself I would have had a
better what the [ __ ] I never had a
chance to challenge myself because I
never challenged myself in school ever
throughout life so when I had the good
grades and I could have transferred
everywhere I was like I don't want to
wait a year I'm just gonna go to the
easiest thing you're downplaying it
you're downplaying yourself you need to
tell them catch them up to speed of like
how dope you are and what type of person
actually gets into universities only
geniuses that's what he thought you
thought that what I thought you had to
be Einstein or some top-notch straight-a
student what did you learn this from I
just created it in my head because I
went into I went to a really bad school
system and then like it was somehow
drilled into me that the standard was
everybody's gonna work at Target or
McDonald's or whatever that's normal and
then only really genius people go to
college and then save the world
hmm so I was like that's not for me I'm
not that smart isn't that
amazing and he's here today dude but
look at you now you got to pay news
globally killing it on the Internet dude
two shelves of snacks company talked
about the snacks of your own company so
you should you don't change anything cuz
you're here now and you guys are doing
this
no run no regrets no why would you
change anything you know what you're
right you're right so you just talked
about hogs Mellie your asses and how you
enjoyed a smile I know I know
amazing that's good you're free a good
life you're making a living talking
about how your ass smells like no one
else can do that no one holiday yeah
your people you're right go to jail or
get a restraining order for that look it
up your dress show them your socks look
at that these are amazing sauce it's
alright don't worry about it don't worry
about it no I don't like doing that you
drop the dress that's though I like
target oh that's what I would do if I
could went back to school I would
actually utilize target more you
couldn't back then records aside I
couldn't afford it target was a horrible
back it was like Kmart
but although all the rich kids I saw
would always go to Target those are poor
kids bro now it's all theirs dorm room
stuff they're at Target no it was really
bad yeah that's how poor you were dude
I would definitely bring like better
bedding cuz the dorm the dorm room beds
are like hard as a rock
yeah not good for digging things okay is
the 18 year old male in China amazing
okay buddy so this dude so he's from
China right so in China because of the
one child policy that they had from 1979
to 2050
there's way more let them up then girls
there's a hundred and thirty boys for
every 100 girls damn don't fart again
[ __ ] did you eat speed go back to
college does that what's give me the gas
no that with the combination of sesame
oil
he ended up applying to women's
University in Beijing but they do accept
about 15 male students as many as 15
male students I get it or ever and then
they have a thousand five hundred female
student it's cuz he needs to go to
college because he's not getting
accepted into other universities well
that's not the problem is just that he
admitted during his interview video
which went viral that so one of the main
reasons why he applied there was because
he wanted to up his chances in finding a
companion since there is you know what's
funny he's a good-looking guy
but is he 36 skews 18 that's a nice suit
that's a grown man this is the first
time I've ever seen someone that looks
that's a nice suit yeah so there's a
there's a shortage of women in China
yeah there's not enough there's not
enough women come on China you think
guys that die without ever [ __ ] well
they're saying that that's some sad [ __ ]
I know ya specialists are saying that
there will be millions of Chinese men in
the upcoming decades that won't be able
to find a partner I bet you nothing
wrong with that man strip clubs and
brothels are gonna be the best
businesses it's like a flashlight or
making your own but they're gonna watch
kids they want companionship bro
yeah but robots will be in effect by
there that's smart
what year are we talking okay couple
years in a couple years ten years their
comment decade
mm 28 right see that just get a robot
girlfriend Joe right yeah yeah you're
right they're already doing it now they
got the test models right now I saw one
alpha I saw this one real doll that
there was a meme going around right and
it was like if real dolls are like this
or like in the future sex dolls are like
this in the future then girls have
something to be careful for some [ __ ]
like that and I was like damn
so you guys wouldn't feel threatened of
these robots these female robot No
would you feel threatened do you guys
feel threatened by other girls though uh
with you know challenge Ellis you don't
know how to flirt so no I don't get
jealous they'll probably be so creeped
out by your flirting I'm like sorry
girls he's trying he's trying I'm like
that too I'm just like you creepy dude
I'm creepy too
what do you mean like creepy like it
just comes off example I'm a girl what
do you say go to flirt you wanna play
yeah you're only gonna kill me you want
to play that you're friends with Stevie
and he smells is about whole yeah
there's a lot that it yeah I used to
just eat at the sorority the sororities
the white sororities had their own like
food court yeah at the bottom of you
know where they live yeah just go in
there and like eat at their Taco Bell
and just like stare at them just eating
like that's [ __ ] creepy black guy
weird dude your that you're being that
stereotype the perverted weird Asian guy
that's pretty bad
yeah yeah yeah yeah
to talk to them I don't know what they
say I didn't know what to say I'm
playing yeah I could have at least try
it's with something I mean that's what
about that dog right guys
dokie talk about this we could have said
start a conversation that's [ __ ]
weird - no don't listen got this logins
you know no one teaches you these things
growing up in the school systems you my
dad never taught me was too busy working
all the time who's supposed to teach
that you know like someone supposed to
teach you right you gotta figure it out
exactly so with your kid what are you
gonna do Bart tell him do you want to
play no no you know what maybe you
should talk thank you
yeah I will so what are you gonna tell
your son you know like as far as game
and picking up on yeah oh just be
confident be yourself do you wanna play
the classic bags do you want to play say
one more time
you want time when he gets for the age
you know puberty yeah
[Music]